se le conoce como el autor de la mayor
estafa piramidal de la historia de wall
street originaria de un barrio obrero en
judío de nueva york- bernie madoff
inició su carrera en el mundo financiero
con tan sólo 22 años cuenta haber
fundado su primera empresa con cinco mil
dólares con los años se convirtió en
leyenda de wall street logró atraer a su
firma incluso a celebridades como el
director de cine steven spielberg y a
grandes empresarios como propietarios de
equipos de béisbol o de fútbol americano
con la reglamentación actual es
prácticamente imposible violar las
reglas es imposible violar las reglas
sin ser detectado al menos no durante un
largo período observo peor y doctor tal
y como lo afirmaba en 2008 fue detenido
poco después se declaró culpable aseguró
entonces estar profundamente arrepentido
y avergonzado había desarrollado un
sistema financiero fraudulento que
prometía grandes ganancias a sus
clientes éstos provenían de los últimos
inversores que confiaban en su gestión
al destaparse su estafa se descubrió que
había causado pérdidas por valor de 65
mil millones
dólares a 37 mil víctimas en 136 países
la justicia lo condenó a 150 años de
cárcel en 2020 su defensa había
solicitado su liberación anticipada al
asegurar que le quedaban tan solo 18
meses de vida sin embargo la justicia le
negó la libertad en junio al alegar que
muchas víctimas aún sufrían las
consecuencias de sus estafas a la
actualidad las autoridades han logrado
recuperar unos 13 mil millones de los
175 mil millones que madoff alcanzó a
reunir con su negocio